et bonjour madame le breizh je suis bien
dans les films autant rapport clément et
à autant n'importe qui n'importe où qui
rapporte le principal c'est qu'on passe
un bon moment parce que la dernière fois
qu'on la vie c'était en plein air
l'écrin s'est envolé avant la fin à
l'automne et madame étiquettes des
places s'il vous plaît comment où est la
deuxième personne n'est à l'abri
c'est mon chien goliath rassurez vous il
est très propre ni pont ni pis ni pinès
et il fait pipi là on lui dit faire
passer le fauteuil à il fera des sous
alors tenez voilà les pourboires et
garder garder la monnaie à la new as
well as non nous asseoir pardon messier
ouhlala je vous ai monté sur les pieds
et à cesser de notre dame et excusez moi
madame et je me suis trompé des pieds à
la mets toi là goliath
aulas
j'arrête de faire la game belle et le
clochard d' on l'a déjà vu trois fois le
cinéma ce n'est pas fait pour les chiens
comment madame je suis assis si votre
manteau ça me dérange pas et il m'a
froissé et bien levé les suivent à foix
sais c'est qu'on vous a vendue de la
saleté télérama 4 caleçons molletonnés
garantie infroissable goliath lui
l'heure n'est pas obligé lui mais quand
même ça sentir anti viol
et pourtant c'est un mal mais je ne peux
pas les premiers cinq minutes sans qu'on
gagne y fourrer le nez dans ses affaires
l'autre fois c'était un pharmacien un
dalmatien un molosse
heureusement il était mise et les relais
profité pour les bottés ricky il a filé
sans demander les restes un goliath
comment monsieur de quelle race il est
il est française autant que vous
peut-être pas de père en fils mais sa
mère un gratin dauphinois un griffon de
pékinois a été croisée par surprise par
un bouledogue japonaise un kamikaze
comme dans la guerre du feu de ipapy la
guerre dit fait quand elle ses pages au
bord de la rivière ou se laver manger
mal à hilton s'est passé le savons pas
qui est qui et les voilà partis
c'était même pas interdit au moins de 13
ans au long du projet il est à moi comme
mon petit neveu de 9 ans m'a demandé ton
temps qu'est ce qui lui a fait à la dame
les messieurs heureusement je n'ai pas
perdu mon sang-froid
je lui ai rien répondu il ya des fois
faut savoir parler aux enfants
alors pour en prévenir mon chien il a
pris la tête à son père et les restes à
sa mère personne n'est pas recette qui
on appelle ça un chiffre bas régime au
bras comme ça se prononce commis mais
dis donc toi petit voyou ça finit
délicat des grimaces comment ça c'est
lui qui a commencé
il grimace passé sa tête qu'il est comme
ça c'est pas beau de se moquer ne les
connaissez pas vous bon sang vous voyez
pas qui ça lui plaît pas un
j'ai caressé par votre femme moineaux je
prends une femme c'est un chien vous
voulez savez que c'est un chien mais lui
est ce qu'il laissait ça y est en voilà
un des 1 mètre 90 il faut qu'ils se
mettent juste devant goliath est bien
moins chihuahua chiwa rien on va
l'entendre il a payé sa place comme tout
le monde c'est bah oui monsieur c'est
après vous qu'il en a non non il mord
prime au point haut débit prévient
que vous avez trois minutes pour changer
des places ne faut pas se fier à
l'apparence d'un flair des chiens
policiers ou pour jo il ya une dame l'a
laissé tomber sa broche en or massif et
bord il a avalé qui est pour l'emmener
chez les métairies né voulait qu'on lui
fasse ouvrir les banques je dirais
d'îlots mon chien c'est pas une tuerie
va pas les casser pour vous faire
plaisir nos médias en a pour 1 million
je dis bon c'est de l'argent placé on
n'est pas des sauvages même